régulièrement dans la rue en garde elle
est dégueulasse où vous êtes dégueulasse
vous devriez vous occupez d'oufa ça
c'est un monde qui vient souvent vrai
bonjour je m'appelle gabriel j'ai 40 ans
et je suis là co réalisatrice du
documentaire on achève bien les gros je
mesure 1 m 54 et je pèse 125 kg mon imc
est entre 52 et 53
j'ai tendance à dire que je mesure in
kylie minogue et que jean ps3 et ce
titre en fait pour moi il veut vraiment
dire ce qui se passe en fait avec les
gros comment on traite les gros dans
cette société
ces gros on ne veut pas pour travailler
on ne veut pas dans les loyers dans
toute l'industrie du loisir n'y a pas de
place pour toi parce que tu peux pas
t'asseoir de toute façon au théâtre ou
ou à l'opéra ou au cinéma
t'es gros aujourd'hui on n'a plus qu'une
seule solution est proposée c'est la
chirurgie bariatrique
le titre est violent mais parce que
c'était pour c'était pour parler de
cette situation que vivent les groupes
qui a elle-même violent je vais vous
raconter comment lorsque l'on sort de la
norme
lorsque l'on déborde la vie se complique
trois mondes bien je vais vous raconter
comment je n'ai jamais été épargné pour
ma différence
je viens d'un milieu ultra modeste enfin
on a toujours vécu sous le seuil de
pauvreté quasiment à la maison j'ai
jamais été une enfant mince j'ai
toujours une taille de plus que mes
camarades et à l'adolescence alors que
je faisais 65 kg et que j'ai voulu
perdre 10 kilos
je suis allé voir un médecin qui m'a
fait un bilan hormonal est en fait il ya
eu une erreur de diagnostic des
traitements hormonaux pour la faire
courte
j'ai d'abord pris 28 kilos en trois mois
puis 60 ans une année et et en parallèle
on m'a fait faire des régimes qui ont
totalement ruiné mon rapport à la
nourriture et qui ont engendré en fait
des des compulsions alimentaires et donc
cette adolescente de 65 kg qui voulaient
en perdre 10 e s'est retrouvé en faire
120 et et avoir un rapport à
l'alimentation complètement d'evian et
est malade
l'hyperphagie c'est le fait de manger en
grande quantité sur une période très
réduite mais sans jamais se faire vomir
en fait
enfin l'hyperphagie face et gargantua
c'est quelque chose qui peut arriver
plusieurs fois par jour c'est c'est
quelque chose qui peut vous réveiller la
nuit je me définis comme une junkie de
la bouffe
il a fallu comprendre que j'avais une
addiction à la nourriture
j'avais l'impression d'être un
vide-ordures en fait quand je vis des
mon frigo je le vis des comme on va
jeter ses poubelles en fait c'est jamais
du plaisir c'est jamais s'est jamais à
je vais me faire un éclair au chocolat
ça va être génial non enfin on peut
ouvrir une boîte de raviolis il a mangé
à même la boîte enfin
[Musique]
qu'on voit mon corps et qu'on voit mon
corps en mouvement ça c'était c'était
vraiment important et le maillot c'est
venu tout de suite afin moi j'étais
prête à faire une interview tout nu à
mais ce n'est pas possible non pas parce
que je manque de pudeur mais c'était
parce que en me mettant en maillot je
n'avais pas besoin d'avoir le discours
de est-ce que je m'accepte ou pas en
fait nous droit ce qui montre sa peau
c'est encore censuré aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux est donc montrer se
corse était aussi je pense que c'était
aussi compenser le fait qu'on voit
jamais ces corps là je suis pas dans un
discours c'est génial et regardez je
suis en maillot c'est juste bah voilà
oui je suis je suis cette personne là
aujourd'hui obèses et et je me suis
empêchée de vivre et m'empêcher de vivre
ça a contribué à alimenter toutes mes
pulsions aimé compulsion avec la
nourriture ne plus m'excuser d'être
grosse ça m'a pris du temps parce qu'il
a fallu que j'écrive le livre c'est pas
pour autant que j'aime ce corps enfin
moi ce corps je n'aime pas mais je fais
avec parce que j'ai que lui quoi
[Musique]
la phrase qui m'a vraiment marqué c'est
le recruteur qui me dit le qi le
quotient intellectuel est inversement
proportionnelle à la liste de masse
corporelle plus vous êtes gros plus vous
êtes idiots enfin c'est ça que ça veut
dire mais alors pas de bol ça dans mon
cas moncuit est supérieur à mon poids et
c'est une performance
une femme obèse et huit fois moins
employables qu'une femme qui ne l'est
pas avoir tous ses camarades de la fac
de sciences po qui bossent tous dans des
instituts de sondage dans des journaux
dans des et moi être surveillant dans un
collège trois femmes c'est ça aussi en
fait cette discrimination et enfin la
grossophobie c'est quelque chose qui
enfin qu'il amène des gens au suicide de
face c'est quelque chose qui amène les
gens dans des états hyper rock sûr c'est
pas parce qu'il est gros qu'il faut le
discriminé c'est pas de sa faute on
trouve 8 enfin un peu de patrons à
pourquoi un peu bah je sais pas quand on
commence à avoir qu'on commence à
prendre du poids faut prendre des
mesures fin essayez au moins de d'éviter
de le devenir
on commença à prendre en compte la
grossophobie comme une réelle
discrimination et du coup on en parlait
et on a même fait rentrer le mot
grossophobie dans le dictionnaire donc
donc il ya une évolution à ce niveau là
dans les faits deux
du quotidien pas pas du tout et toujours
pas en tout cas au niveau au niveau de
l'embauché enfin il ya les failles est
toujours ces discriminations la fin là
je pense honnêtement qu'il va falloir
éduquer des générations de drh j'ai pas
envie que les gens ils me disent que je
suis belle
j'ai envie que les gros et soit juste
traité comme comme tout le monde en fait
est que et que baïse et autant de
chances que n'importe qui quand il
tendit date un agent à partir du moment
où on se sent à intégrer dans la société
il ya au moins deux raisons d'être
dépressif il ya personne qui mérite
qu'on se fasse du mal et personne qui
mérite qu on s'empêche à faire quoi que
ce soit en fait aujourd'hui long c'est
évident que faire si un médecin prescrit
un régime je ne vais plus voir ce
médecin et je ne comprends pas qu'on
continue à les prescrire en fait parce
qu'on sait que le taux d'échec d'un
régime c'est 95% que refusent les
régimes et je refuse l'opération mais
c'est pas incompatible avec le fait de
maigrir
on